[Music]
on this Saturday night defiance
demonstrations blockades remain in place
across the country despite a plea from
the prime minister we will die depending
on rage + sweat so itand beretta terry
cheeps meet with supporters what's
needed to resolve the dispute kovat 19
concerns why some cases may be going
undetected and 5 years preparing paper
cable to happen allegations of stealing
streaming the lawsuit that could cost
some Canadian consumers
[Music]
global national with Robin Gill
reporting tonight Coleen Christie good
evening thanks for joining us it's been
more than two weeks since protests broke
out across the country in support of
what certain hereditary Chiefs supposed
to a natural gas pipeline in northern BC
yesterday the Prime Minister called for
an end to the blockades but tonight
there doesn't appear to be an end in
sight now Sean O'Shay reports in our top
story some protesters are vowing to die
for the cause as the standoffs continues
supporters in Toronto made something
clear from right outside the Ontario
legislature hundreds rallied to defend
indigenous blockades in British Columbia
and Ontario and one Mohawk supporter
warned it's a fight they won't give up
there is no way we're backing down
absolutely no way we will be here til
the end even if we have to die doing it
we will die defending our rights I know
my father and their hereditary Chiefs
aren't budging hereditary Chiefs from
bc's wood so it's a nation met with
leaders from the Connor walky Mohawk
territory in Quebec I think it went fine
but it's not over yet the stories that
they told us we're very touching the red
eteri Chiefs want a halt to construction
on the coastal gas pipeline that crosses
their land that dispute has spawned
protests like this one at the tie and
Onaga Mohawk territory in Ontario which
has halted freight and passenger rail
service but another rail blockade south
of Montreal came down peacefully Friday
night as police moved in to enforce a
court injunction earlier in the day
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau said all
the blockades must come down but there
is no sign that will happen counter
protesters agree it's time now it's time
to get back to work and we do
supporters who marched through downtown
Toronto streets say employment isn't the
most important thing jobs are secondary
this is people's way of living and if we
need to sacrifice the jobs of a few
which are in the hands of corporate
interests when we must do so to protect
the future it is up to the governments
to get it sorted out on terms that are
respectful of indigenous sovereign
nations provincial and federal
governments have asked the Wood soliton
for meetings not have been scheduled so
far leaving blockades like this one up
into another week Sean O'Shay Global
News Toronto as world health experts
recalculate the risk of kovat 19:00 and
the evolution of the outbreak another
quarantine is under way here in Canada
151 Canadians woke up in quarantine in
Cornwall Ontario 129 of them were
passengers on a diamond Princess cruise
ship the others were helping to get
those stranded passengers back to Canada
after hundreds of people on the ship
became infected they'll stay in
quarantine for two weeks meanwhile
Canadians quarantined for 14 days in
Trenton Ontario are enjoying their first
full day of freedom
195 Canadians remain under quarantine at
CFB Trenton but they're expected to be
released on Tuesday 48 other Canadians
who are on board the diamond princess
have tested positive for the virus
today Japanese officials confirmed
another passenger released this week
after completing the cruise ships
quarantine also tested positive the
woman in her sixties is the first known
case among those released at the end of
the ship's containment period a sixth
person has died from the virus in Iran
as cases there continue to rise the
country is reporting at least 10 new
cases today bringing its total to at
least 28 middle-eastern neighbors
including Iraq are now closing their
borders to Iranian Nationals another
major outbreak is in South Korea two
people are dead and cases are exploding
there 229 new cases have been confirmed
since Friday skyrocketing south korea's
total number to more than 430 cases a
dozen towns in northern
we're in lockdown today after two people
infected with the virus died and 39
cases were recorded 19 passengers on
board the diamond princess returned to
Italy this week and the country is
ramping up its response to the outbreak
so as you can see cases are multiplying
around the world in countries where
travel bans to and from China have been
in effect 28 countries are now reporting
cases the Center for global infectious
disease analysis in London which
collaborates with the World Health
Organization on modeling to contain the
disease estimates two-thirds of kovat 19
cases from China have remained
undetected worldwide right now there are
more than 77,000 confirmed cases 1,500
of those are in countries outside of
China more than 2000 people have died
mostly in China but there's concerned
sources of human-to-human transmission
are going unchecked which will lead to a
spike in cases there are some troubling
revelations tonight about a respected
Canadian religious figure an internal
report from large international says its
founder Jean Vanier sexually abused at
least six women according to the report
there is enough evidence to show Vanya
engaged in manipulative sexual
relationships over a 35-year period
Vanier who died last year founded the
charity in 1964 to help improve
conditions for people living with
developmental disabilities it now has
facilities in 38 countries in a
statement L'Arche France says there is
no evidence people with disabilities or
affected Democratic supporters in Nevada
are voting for a candidate to defeat and
drive US President Donald Trump from
office senator Bernie Sanders holds a
double-digit lead in the latest poll
after taking the New Hampshire primary
he now admits he's been told Russia is
trying to interfere in his campaign as
Jennifer Johnson reports Trump seems to
welcome the liberal as his political
opponent Nevada Democrats gathering to
caucus the third contest in the 2020
primary season Vermont senator Bernie
Sanders so confident of a win he spent
part of Friday campaigning in California
but
14 states that holds votes March third
Super Tuesday and if we win here in
California we're going to win the
Democratic nomination and if we win the
Democratic nomination Donald Trump is a
one-term president Sanders now confirms
he was briefed by intelligence officials
a month ago that Russia is attempting to
interfere in his campaign and president
Trump's here's an otter crack he may be
a friend of Donald Trump's he's not a
friend of mine campaigning in Nevada
President Trump seemed eager to take on
Sanders confident no swing voter will
endorse the senators higher taxes and
free health care policies this November
we're going to defeat the radical
socialist Democrats here at least 75,000
Nevada Democrats cast their ballots in
early voting a record turnout and unlike
New Hampshire in Iowa Nevada is a much
more diverse State Sanders is getting
strong support from the Latin American
community everything is going to be here
in these caucuses making a difference
that's what it's all about
we represent the real face of American
the other candidates are trying to stop
Sanders momentum most in the party agree
a more moderate nominee is needed
pundits are predicting a world where
pretty soon the only two left standing
are Mike Bloomberg and Bernie I'm really
worried about our ability to defeat
Donald Trump if those are our choices
Michael Bloomberg was not on the Nevada
ballot but after taking a beating in
last week's Las Vegas debate the former
New York Mayor has announced he'll
release three women who lodged
complaints against the billionaire
businessman from non-disclosure
agreements allowing them to tell their
stories if they want to Bloomberg is
hoping to get some traction on Super
Tuesday but Sanders could effectively
secure the Democratic presidential
nomination March 3rd if voters don't
back an alternative Coleen Jennifer
Johnson in Washington Jennifer thank you
the US and the Taliban began a partial
truth this morning setting the stage for
the two sides to sign a peace deal that
would end America's longest war if the
week-long pact holds the two sides have
agreed to meet on February 29th
to lay out a timetable for the u.s. to
withdraw its troops from Afghanistan the
18 year conflict has just passed a grim
milestone according to the United
Nations more than 100,000 civilians have
been killed or injured since it began
documenting casualties a decade ago
coming up four popular Canadian
retailers are being sued for allegedly
helping their customers steal streaming
content they deny it but could customers
be liable
five BC teams were honored by the
governor-general today Julie Payette
presented the group with challenge coins
in honor of their heroic actions last
February the team's rescued an 8 year
old boy who was dangling from a
chairlift at a Vancouver area ski hill
cell phone video captured them grabbing
some nearby fencing then coaxing the boy
to fall into the makeshift net really
good being like recognized by so many
people that you can look up to
yeah but throughout your community
whether they've been here for like years
or seven months they're all really good
people do recognize bye
I really appreciate that the boys are
also skiing for free this season
receiving complimentary passes for their
heroic actions a lawsuit filed in
Alberta provincial court is raising
questions about how popular media
streaming devices are being used and
whether consumers can be held
responsible if they're used to watch
illegal content the suit was filed by
Alec o entertainment the company that
owns super Channel it's suing four
popular Canadian retailers including
Best Buy London Drugs and staples
accusing them of selling piracy devices
and teaching customers how to use them
Heather York's West explains my wife and
I dated about a year ago we went to the
Android box I even got my cable down to
beta this is hidden-camera footage of
interactions between an undercover
investigator hired by alar Co
Entertainment the parent company of
super Channel and the personal Arco
alleges is a salesperson at London Drugs
one of four retailer's named in a
lawsuit before the Alberta provincial
court here's another investigator
alleged to be at Staples the Premium TV
network is using the videos as evidence
in a 50 million dollar lawsuit against
London Drugs staples Best Buy and Canada
computers in the statement of claim
super channels parent company accuses
the retailers of contributing to the
creation of a culture of widespread
infringement and theft accusing them of
selling internet streaming devices that
allow users to access streaming content
for free and having employees direct
their customers to purchase them
so that they can steal programming they
should pay
we were kind of shocked when we first
learned that they were educating
consumers on actually how the steel
global news reached out to the four
retailers for comment in statements
London Drugs disputes the allegations
and says in part it would never
intentionally infringe intellectual
property rights while Best Buy said the
suits claims were without merit
staples declined comment while Canada
computers did not respond to our
requests for comments
Ilario was suing the store's customers
as well listing them for now in the
claim as john doe's because the company
doesn't yet know who they are though it
hopes to find out could a consumer be
liable for copyright infringement using
a device in a way that it wasn't
intended to be used i suppose
theoretically yes this copyright lawyer
says Larco will have to prove that these
so-called piracy devices don't have
legitimate uses on their own court
filings don't specify what these devices
are but in an interview with Global News
super channel CEO Don McDonald says they
are Android devices preloaded with
software typically Kodi
software and basically Cooley software
is intended to to be used for stealing
contents off the internet in a statement
to global news the US nonprofit behind
Kodi says the software does not provide
any support for pirated video content
other people including some software
developers misuse it by adding to it
encouraging users to perform unlawful
activities we at Cody have never
authorized these and condemned such uses
in the past out of our very scant
resources we have worked in cooperation
with media companies on such matters to
check illegal activities and we will
continue to do so tech industry expert
Graham Williams says Cody has plenty of
legal applications as well they're not
piracy devices their computers and their
computers that run software and they
have perfectly legitimate uses coming
soon trailers twitch for video games
VEVO TV for music videos the problem is
those pirated streams exist online tubes
that could potentially contain content
licensed to broadcasters like super
channel who
was responsible for those losses is
something an Alberta provincial court
may have to decide as his lawsuit
proceeds in the months ahead
Heather Eric's West Global News Calgary
still ahead a field of schemes how the
ghosts of the games past are haunting
Major League Baseball
the first spring training games in Major
League Baseball are being played today
but for months the sport has been facing
backlash from its worst scandal in a
century mic delay looks at how the
houston astros went from being baseball
champions to pariahs baseball spring
training is a time for renewal there are
no winners or losers yet and what
happened in previous seasons is
forgotten except this year when it comes
to the Houston Astros a team embroiled
in baseball's worst cheating scandal of
the past century and now the sports
world is up in arms even basketball star
LeBron James is disgusted the Houston's
2017 World Series trophy hasn't been
taken away I don't think it holds any
value with you know you cheated and you
didn't earn it you know that's that's
how I feel is it wasn't earned I feel
like every single guy over there needs a
beating you know it's wrong genuine
anger underscoring these comments is is
something that I haven't really ever
seen before
in my experience following and covering
Major League Baseball the cheating
scheme was as high-tech as it was simple
the Astros arranged for the camera feed
that recorded the opposing teams
catchers signals to be relayed to their
dugout the batter was in turn tipped off
to what pitch was coming by someone
banging on a garbage can in baseball
knowing what's coming is a huge
advantage the Astros coach and general
manager were both fired the team was
fined but no players were disciplined
they were granted immunity in exchange
for their cooperation with the
investigation if somebody grants the
immunity then they can take that back
and just punish you after they told you
that you have immunity baseball
commissioner Rob Manfred has defended
the punishment I think if you look at
the faces of the houston players as
they've been out there publicly
addressing this issue they have been
hurt by this they will live with
questions about what went on in 2017 and
2018 for the rest of their lives
but now Manfred is coming under fire
from players and fans who are furious
the Astros cheated to win the World
Series and
say he hasn't done enough to deter teens
from doing it again Manfred isn't
helping himself referring to baseball's
championship trophy something he
personally awards to the winners like
something he found in the garage the
idea of you know an asterisk or asking
for a piece of metal back seems you know
sort of a futile Act people are always
know that there was something about the
2017 World Series
so baseball it's Commissioner and the
Astros a World Series contender again
this year must now deal with both the
cheating scandal and the botched
handling of the whole thing none of the
millionaire players will lose any salary
but they still have to play a hundred
and sixty two games and should expect
questions and heckling all summer long
it's gonna be bad everywhere they are
going to get it from all the twenty-nine
other fan bases and that includes here
in Toronto where the Blue Jays have
their own connections to the scandal one
of their coaches Dave Hudgens was the
Astros hitting coach while others
cheating was going on he's been
tight-lipped about his role in it other
than to say that he fully cooperated
with the investigation the Blue Jays say
they're sticking by him Colleen Mike
delay in Toronto Mike thanks up next
enabling dance how a late cellist
inspired a modern ballet
[Applause]
[Music]
Quade n' is the nine-year-old indigenous
boy from australia whose deep distress
of him constant bullying at school
captured hearts around the world now
center stage at a major sporting match
Down Under he let out the indigenous
all-stars a team stacked with his rugby
league heroes for an exhibition match
against the New Zealand Maori Quentin
has dwarfism but a huge heart and was
all smiles as he ran on the field his
mother who posted the viral video says
he always dreamt of being a rugby league
star the story of a young woman's
struggle with multiple sclerosis is
taking center stage in London
Jacqueline de Prague was a
world-renowned musician when she was
diagnosed with the debilitating disease
it robbed her of her greatest love the
cello but as crystal commencing reports
more than three decades after her death
a ballet is giving new life to her work
[Music]
a mixture of elegance and ferocity
that's how Jacqueline du prais playing
of the cello was once categorized the
story of her multiple sclerosis
diagnosis at 26 shared through dance
will be familiar to many with the
disease
it began with numbness and unexplained
sensations so I started to dream up this
story which is about her it's to some
extent of biographical work but it's
very much focused on the love affair
that she had with music and I liked the
idea of personifying music and the cello
and by using a male dancer in that role
there's a neck of the cello there's a
body of the cello
Kathy Marston got the idea for the
cellist from her sister a music teacher
Duprey was a young English musical icon
I really wanted to take care that and I
was portraying the illness with as much
sensitivity and poetry as poses as I
possibly could
la explores the height that she flew to
and then it sort of the loss of her
voice MS often strikes people early in
life women are diagnosed more than men
there's no cure and for some it can take
a devastating toll there's no telling
what what the future holds
some people will lose mobility some
people won't that the path is very
different so it's a it's a really
interesting way to tell the story
through movement I think a very powerful
one
Duprey had relapsing remitting ms it
crept through her fingers and eventually
she was confined to a wheelchair she
died at 42 the Royal Opera House in
London has partnered with cinemas around
the world to broadcast the cellist so
far only two small Canadian theatres are
slated to run it one NBC the other in
Ontario
I think it is an emotional work and it's
it's heartbreaking but it's not tragic
we should be celebrating the life force
of Jackie as much as the loss of her
talent Marsten's mum also has MS she
hopes the ballet will raise awareness
while bringing people a little joy
Christo go Manson Global News London
that is global national for this
Saturday I'm Colleen Christie tonight's
your Canada is English Bay and Vancouver
we love seeing your Canada email your
pictures to viewers in global national
calm thanks for watching we'll be back
here tomorrow good night
[Music]